okay guys right now based on the title
and thumbnail you know that i'll be
unboxing or showing off the new star
wars black series darth vader helmet
this is the same helmet they'll be
getting with the ob1 series itself we've
already opened this up put in the
batteries and if you can see the entire
box itself you have no idea that this is
from the ob1 series itself box is very
different from the one we had back in
2018 we'll show that off later as well
and make some comparisons
but this is how pretty much how it looks
like if you're not interested with this
section please skip on ahead to actually
look at how the helmet looks like anyway
here's the manual guys the only way that
we know that this is from the star wars
obi-wan kenobi series on disney plus is
on this section here that's pretty much
it
that's all
manual you gotta put in two batteries
where the magnets go where your the car
goes and that's pretty much it okay
let's go check it out what is in here
okay let's get the safe lock in if you
guys are very familiar with this camera
angle i do this quite a bit with our
gaming channel where i do a lot of mtg
unboxings but here we go this is darth
vader and it's all his glory itself
we're gonna show off the different parts
of this helmet this is the 2022 version
the previous one came out in 2018 and
let's go check it out i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna just open up it's all held
together by magnets pretty sturdy
magnets there we go
first part goes up and you can see these
are magnets that are securing the
section down
batteries uh are energy and if you look
his visors are red it's a bit of a
continuing team i was saying
how much the original ones that's why
they changed it to the red ones the
previous ones in 2018 were just all
black some people were wondering why his
visors read i think it just looks more
menacing let's see at the side here
it is this is button here which you can
use to turn on the audio which is his
breaths
and bring it closer to the mic so you
guys can hear
what do you guys think
if you're wondering if there's a voice
modulator to this no this doesn't change
your voice at all it just pretty much
okay
let me going back on the stand again to
give you guys another look at how this
thing actually comes off you can
actually remove this section here
and pull it off
there and it makes the sound as well not
sure if you guys heard it you can
actually put it back again
oh that's so cool
but let me rip it off
this is how it looks like from the back
so if you're using looking to use this
as cosplay they recommend you to
actually wear the next section here and
there's this over your face as well or
is it i'm not sure let me check the
manual but you guys need to be very
careful and actually affords quite a bit
of space if you look at it
i think the the thicker part is actually
this neck area here
but we can look at it let's check it out
guys the visors itself when we favor the
camera a bit you can see the detail on
the inside
pretty nice
and
padding right on the top so that it does
not weigh down too much on your head
and these are adjustable straps as well
i'm not sure if many folks will be using
this for full-on cosplay because i'm not
not certain how well ventilated this is
but
it is uh pretty impressive looking to
the front you can see all the
electronics here very nice chrome and
paint job you can see that there are a
bit of you can see the seal joints here
overall construction is pretty good
and if you have missed out in the 2018
version
this is definitely something you want to
pick up
okay let me put him down one side and
let's go on to the neck piece once again
neck piece they're cutting no corners
here hasbro has been doing well this is
all removable i saw from the manual
let's check it out see it just comes off
like that
ah there's a different audio
do you guys hear that the audio is
actually different if you put it on and
put it off and you can see
these sections here are all
different as well we'll have a closer
look at how it looks like compared to
the 2018 model but tell what do you
think in the comment section below we'll
be getting this this is pretty awesome
okay um let's hear it again once again
[Music]
it's like gasping
[Applause]
[Music]
okay let me show you guys the battery
section as well here's the battery
section takes two double a batteries
pretty straightforward you got two screw
it in
and that's the
next section back bridge section let's
put on his helmet
[Music]
with the sound
audio changes guys
and finally we got the helmet here
tada
darth vader
safe lord
and
let's go and compare it with the 2018
version i'm gonna snap bam okay we've
got these two now in
in the frame itself let me see if i can
get this stand properly it looks like
it's angled slightly differently from
what i'm looking right now the 18
version tends to be tilted down
is there something wrong with the stand
okay it's looking good right now
let's bring them all up for the camera
see what's the difference these guys i
hate
i think you can see immediately from the
cow the
the mouth guard area
is different there's a different paint
job we can see there's a bit more gun
metal similar to the nose piece here but
otherwise aesthetically it's pretty
similar and uh the eye pieces as well
which is different right now the
eyepieces for the 2018 one i'm going to
show for the camera once again
this
is black
whereas
this is more a translucent red light
sunglasses
i think it's a pretty good look okay
let's take them off part by part so you
guys can see how each of them differs so
let's take off the
2022 ob1 version first
put in one side
trying to give you guys as much possible
visuals as much as possible
um you see this 2018 version we have had
it for quite some time sits in the
office
there's a bit of dust
okay guys check it out it's a different
paint pins uh paint job small gun metal
here
take a look
how it differs
and
this one as
well it's very different oh it's a
uniform color for the 2018 one as
opposed to a mix of a silver gunmetal
for the 2022 ob1 darth vader helmet
batteries have been put in put into this
as well so let's listen to the sound
let's remove this one
not as loud
not as loud as the
2018 i think it's down to
the batteries
and over time this is you can see i
think there's a bit of a slight rust if
i'm seeing it correctly otherwise
pretty much the same let's take off the
brand new 2022 version as well
come on
i think you can see
this vader helmet here
is angled slightly lower
actually not slightly quite a bit
and i counted actually down to the
neck brace area this part is so much
much more fuller constructed as opposed
to the 2018
one
might be easier for for you to wear on
your head um not going to try it for now
we're going to see if it's better oh you
can see the construction is different as
well so the the seams here is in the
middle
and the ones here is by the side so
there's like three pieces
four pieces additional pieces
this is where the difference is actually
nice
okay let's see a sound
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that was the one that we saw with
the 202 version
let's go with the
2018 version
hmm
pretty much the same
paint job wise let's look what's on the
inside
is there any difference
no it looks pretty much the same to me
how
both of these sections look like let's
put this let's assemble it all back
again
nice you can feel the class of the
magnets there
same same audio sound board that they
have
and let's put on the
and vader is complete
so shiny i can see myself in the lights
in this
helmet itself okay guys those are
initial thoughts i think this is a
pretty cool
cool update to folks who had missed it
in 2018 and are looking to get in 2022
updated the difference here metal i
think i prefer the 2022 vision so much
more it looks more impressive with the
red visor itself much more menacing in
the in the eyes of the
i think if you're facing down rebel scum
okay there you have it a quick overview
of the two helmets that we saw most
recently in star wars
ob1 kenobi
series on disney plus and this is the
classic darth vader helmet main
differences here you can see how it
actually tilts up and let us know what's
your thoughts we will be getting this in
the comments section below and i'll be
happy to answer any questions that you
might have that being said i'm jera from
geek culture and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
you